[Music]
you dare enter this house on Father's
Day you bad [__] pilot to
Bombardier pilot to Bombardier I can't
see nothing I'm not the land in the
Hudson like Sully
that's how we do it on Father's Day you
bad [__] listen don't send your
dad a tie or [__] little pocket knife
for a card you know what he needs
he needs me to sit right next to my boy
a shotgun right in his face old-school
style a from the 70s on it
here you go dead oh just sit there like
a finger bang file you have a finger
bang somebody and they go on that finger
bang [__] far like they sit there
when your finger in like that anyway
what's happening tip-top Magoo the
Lord's Day Father's Day who's better
than you uncle Joey coming to you what
before 9 o'clock post-church some people
at the church they go to Denny's [__] no
I come back to the garden a good and
evil and I [__] sparked this with my
favorite people you know that is you
[__] what up what up it's
Father's Day you get your [__] together
let me tell you something about dads ok
we [__] to kill ourselves for you
[__] every time every time my
mind is fat little [__] girl inside
she doesn't even know it nobody knows I
don't give a [__] about anything I don't
give a [__] about anything but that
little girl outside even my wife better
have some [__] doubt she's I'm saying
so do me a favor when you were young
didn't know what your dad was going
through just for that reason give him a
call say what's up [__] I'm coming
over I'm gonna come home with a bag of
weed and a few pornos to get your
[__] party started whatever whatever
it is man but listen happy Father's Day
know you that's great and everything but
you know what's most important the week
ahead
these [__] will beat think I'm
uppity that's it after next week people
be thinking of my [__] potato salad
the fourth of July and with Chinese
guided by a firecrackers from listen
take over that situation there's the
time the day when they're [__] off
like next two weeks together
I can't wait the potato salad [__]
this your opportunity to spark your
[__] charisma and get a job or
whatever the [__] up you wanna lose you
want to do to be honest the [__] I'm
talking but I've been smoking this pipe
since 10:00 to 6:00 this [__] morning
I went to church I had a little [__]
protein shake now I'm back to that
breakfast with the family I'm gonna
write a little bit they're gonna gonna
let Church I'm gonna go a little jujitsu
and then we're all gonna [__]
collaborate today and do Father's Day
[__] tonight I got a spot at 10:30 at
the store I'm going down to see Paul
Mooney cuz listen Richard Pryor showed
me the door to [__] comedy before
monie kicked that [__] so out of
respect I'm gonna go down and see him
and that's it podcast tomorrow 7 o'clock
Friday and Saturday governor's oh [__]
strong the week before [__] the
fourth of July now you got something to
do you I'm saying your uncle's coming
I'm coming straight in [__] Thursday
I'm packing the Stars the debt will be
out of box on the way to Long Island on
Tuesdays you know me
I don't go nowhere without the [__]
stars the stars will be wet listen sorry
about the control all right it's gonna
be a good week people today after you
give you that love and all that shit's
back to basics back to your goals 22
push-ups and how the [__] you gonna take
over a world this week that's the most
important thing on your mind 24/7 give a
[__] well the political climate I don't
give a [__] about the political climate
the political climate don't do nothing
for you
Kathy Griffin don't do nothing for you
let these [__] to mumfie
know does some feel you that's it unless
you do it ain't gonna [__] happen so
get it together you understand me stop
[__] around life is passing you the
[__] by at least all those years I was
doing criminal activity isn't staying up
and do
more than chlamydia but at least I was
doing something it's better than sitting
there at home waiting for a [__]
missile to hit you in the head Joey
what's with the it beats about that
number I feel the same way
I want to give a shout out to my nephews
my main man Ryan Holloway over and
Secaucus bit slapping [__] I
could tell him Davidson
I got nephews and nieces I got my
favorite [__] nice over there in
Nashville [__] play my guitar I got
my other niece down the [__] Jersey
Shore with three kids and yelling saying
dog I got him all over the place but
anyway back to the conversation we were
having
should we fill up another one let's do
this I got [__] primo today and I've
got the perennial G forget about it you
know how we're doing it though you think
I'm the [__] bother you people find
showing up with two guns with bullets in
it with a fight you know how uncle Joey
[__] rose and this little [__]
creeping out of
we're outside and it's still [__]
smoke people - [__] do you think you're
dealing with if you thought of bonds
with the hump you better show up with
two [__] fresh lungs you understand
me don't forget on the back of your
[__] driver's license if you want to
leave your lungs to somebody I'm
shutting one of these lungs down this
week so just in case yeah I'm saying you
want to leave a lung to somebody check
that and put Lisa okay maybe in hi -
there's the bong I'm getting made it's
gonna blow one of his little [__] Jew
ball eyes right out of his [__] head
that's why I love that [__] but
anyway I'm not here for this tonight I'm
here to tell you it's your week to take
over the [__] world but you knew that
already it's not a man Nietzsche so you
gotta be prepared you got to write
everything down let these [__]
think you're aloof and you're half a
[__] [__] but deep down inside
you're retime you're reading their
[__] lunch you understand me so
that's the plan of the week let them
think one thing but the whole time you
apply pressure you understand me
pressure you [__] a month I don't
even know what I'm talking about I'm so
high the bottom line is tomorrow night
seven o'clock
Churchill what's happened now the bottom
line is dirt Friday night and Saturday
night for [__] shows a
governor's on levee town and besides
that have a great day with your father
you busted his hump for your
[__] go over there bring him a
[__] something to join a tie a
chicken wing and I said I love you
[__] with all my heart have a
great week get ready for a big [__]
week don't worry about what Korea's
doing
the French air and who gives a [__] the
most important thing is what the [__]
you're doing and what the former you're
taking over you understand me
stay black uncle Joey loves you don't
forget about me